and then you decide to be a YouTuber
started 2013. right well I'm like yeah
let me do a video a week called two
minutes with Pat we do 100 videos only
the last video was two minutes
everything else was seven minutes nine
minutes four minutes and then uh we kind
of grown like listen there's an audience
for entrepreneurship let's pick one word
we've been an entrepreneur created a
bunch of business content and I said I'm
not touching politics every time I did
politics Mario would say Pat you're
talking Paul this is not politics but
you said you don't want to do political
content okay let's we can't do this one
let's change it and then eventually I
take a break we're at a like 450 000
subs and I said I'm not doing this right
now we took a three-month break I was
having kids and families busy I'm
traveling six months on the road so I
said if we come back we got to really
compete we got to really do something
with this and then we bought the domain
valuetainment yeah from a publicly
traded company and we picked it up they
changed their company's name to Value
tease then we started changing the
structure we're gonna do some interviews